voilà alors on va regarder un petit peu
la structure du texte c'est quand même
intéressant pour le comprendre c'est un
bouquin qui est pas très loin
ici en format de poche c'est une
centaine de pages ça se lit très très
vite parce que c' est découpé en de
nombreux chapitres une centaine de pages
répartis en 26 chapitres de ça fait
parfois des chapitres d'une bâche ou
d'une phase c'est sympa parce que ça se
lit très vite hein quand un des gros
chapitre c'est très très long à lire
donc ici c'était une lecture et une
lecture très rapide en plus c'est
relativement accessible pour quelque
chose quand même qui date du 16e siècle
alors je comprends pas parce que ici sur
le 4c de la quatrième de couverture ils
nous disent le prince
et quand je vais sur le net
et tout à l'heure j'ai écouté l'émission
pour aussi préparé un petit peu je
regarde un petit peu différente chose
est sûre le net 10-15
115g pas eu l'occasion de vraiment de
vérifier ça
à nos limites m 15 132 alors et aussi
peut-être l'écriture l'écriture de
commencer à 15 115 puisqu'elle le prince
n'a pas publié de son vivant
je pense
nous voilà c'est peut-être ça
ce qu'on dit ici circonstances guy tueur
2498 à 1512 machiavel est employé comme
fonctionnaire de la république
florentine notamment comme les gars
auprès des puissances étrangères comme
la france donc c'est vraiment une
réflexion d'un homme de terrain et ça
c'est assez novateur par rapport à
l'époque où tu as surtout qui écrit bas
les religieux les philosophes commence
un petit peu à écrire des gens comme
montaigne
est-ce que montanier
contemporain moi c'est une période où je
commence pas encore m'intéresse à ce
moment un peu mon autre chose le xvième
siècle puis tout le 17e qui m'intéresse
ouais c'est ça hein montagne c'est qu'un
donc arrivé un peu après ma cave
l1 plus jeune
dans ces eaux là donc on est vraiment
sur le début d'une réflexion
certainement politique certainement
qu'on est aux prémices de ça c'est
vraiment le premier à faire quelque
chose de très bien et des passages qui
sont très intéressants on va voir ça
ensemble alors donc s'est découpé en
vain ou six chapitres
et il ya une asymétrie dans la
construction du livre alors je précise
tout de suite que quand on doit lire
qu'en étudiant quand élèves et qu'on
doit lire rapidement un livre comme
celui ci qui à la base faut le dire ce
qui est c'est chiant à lire parce que tu
as plein de références et un style de
l'époque qui est un peu parfois pénible
je pense que c'est essentiel de bien
d'abord s'intéresser à la structure mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est peut-être
valable aussi pour des écrits
contemporains quand je fais les lecture
de l'article de science sociale quand je
dois lire des choses je regarde toujours
la structure ça permet vraiment d'avoir
l'arborescence quelque part et après une
fois que tu as bien compris cette
structure tu remplis les différents
terroirs quoi les différents terroirs
parce qu'il semble plus intéressant
aussi dans le cadre de ta lecture et
comme tu le dis phoenix aller à
l'essentiel
ça permet de chercher ce que toi tu veux
il trouver quoi il faut pas faim moi je
j'ai parfois une lecture un peu trop
scolaire est un peu trop
respectueuse de l'oeuvre dont j'ai envie
de tout lire et tout ça bien c'est
vraiment avance pas quoi donc je vois un
petit peu me faire violence mais voilà
je maintenant j'arrive à le faire et
donc tu peux comme ça quand tu as la
structure aller ce qui te semble le plus
intéressant surtout dans le cadre d'une
recherche si tu fais une recherche tu
fais un travail voilà tout ne
t'intéresse pas on nous ici on est là
pour découvrir donc on va un peu
papillonner on va un petit peu butiner
dans les différents chapitres alors je
rappelle que je suis pas un spécialiste
de montagne mais toutes façons de
montaigne de machiavel
ni du prince et on découvre sa quasi
ensemble moi j'ai juste fait une
première lecture
pour préparer le stream je me suis
documenté aussi pour voir un petit peu
ce que les auteurs
postérieur en disait et ça je vous
conseille aussi de le faire c'est quand
vous voulez lire un classique c'est
parfois assez difficile pour les raisons
que j'ai déjà évoqué viens moi ce que je
fais je lis d'abord qui t'a pas de
comprendre je lis d'abord en essayant de
comprendre vraiment le sens essentiel à
partir du plan comme je le disais et
puis après je vais un petit peu regardé
ce qu'en disent des auteurs
contemporains ou essayer de choper une
ou deux émissions par exemple sur france
culture d émission de vulgarisation pour
un peu confronter mon ressenti à
la lecture qui a été fait je vais
toujours comme ça et personnellement ça
me permet vraiment d'avancé parce que
déjà que tu valides ou non ta lecture
dans le sens où tu te dis ah bah oui
mais finalement j'avais bien compris la
même chose que cette personne là qui est
plus spécialisée que moi dans cette
question-là s'agit pas de chercher une
validation par par une autorité
extérieure et je dire voilà tu te dis ah
bah oui finalement j'ai pas rater
l'essentiel du truc et puis c'est
parfois ça te permet de revenir sur
certains points certains passages que tu
avais pas forcément bien compris ou pour
lesquels tu n'avais pas senti tout
l'enjeu qu'il y avait dedans moi tu peux
revenir après dessus puisque dont ce que
tu as lu honte a précisé ce qui était
important et des passages qui pouvait
être intéressant
et donc il ya une asymétrie ici
les premiers chapitres c'est vraiment en
fait une analyse politique qu'on vous
comparaissez assez moderne je trouve
après oui c'est un peu un peu grossier
dans le fond mais sur la forme c'est
assez moderne dans le sens où il va
vraiment faire une typologie des
classifications sans tomber dans
l'essentialisme c'est ça qui est qui et
qui est sympa des différentes
principauté donc de différents royaumes
qui peuvent exister et surtout ben
comment leur existence est survenu
est-ce que ça a été facile pour le
prince de d'acquérir ces principautés
aussi donné quelques conseils pratiques
sur comment faire pour les maintenir on
verra ça
puis on rentre dans des considérations
un peu plus pratico pratique avec par
exemple comment gérer la force armée
puisque machiavel pour lui c'est très
important d'avoir une force armée non
pas parce qu'il est forcément
militariste un jeu précis c'est si c'est
correct de parler de militariste quand
on parle de montagne étant donné que
l'autre seizième siècle mais
sans être voilà
vouloir faire la guerre à la terre
entière sait pas ce qu'il veut faire il
n'est pas dans le monde des bisounours
coin ça c'est vraiment du machiavel
c'est toujours mieux à mon sens
selon lui d'avoir l'adhésion des peuples
sur les quelques exercer un pouvoir mais
si tu n'as pas de forces armées un
certain manque risque de te confrontés à
certains problèmes et donc là il est
vraiment sur des considérations
pratiques par rapport à la force
militaire
nous expliquant les différents types de
forces militaires qui peuvent exister
différents types de faction et puis
arrive le chapitre 15 qui est vraiment
très intéressant parce que là il fait
des petites références sur sa
méthodologie alors c'est très succinct
mais il faut pas oublier qu'on est en
cours au xvième siècle dans la première
moitié du xvième siècle et donc c'est
assez novateur pour l'époque donc on
fera un arrêt marqué ça durera pas
forcément longtemps mais en tout cas on
mettra vraiment le focus sur ce chapitre
chapitres 16 de la libéralité et de
l'avarice et là vous voyez qu'on rentre
dans un autre dans une autre dimension
de l'oeuvre qui va être plutôt de voir
quelles sont les qualités quels sont les
défauts des princes qu'est ce qu'ils
doivent faire en tant qu'individu
comment ils doivent se comporter et donc
là on est plus dans la proche très typé
du la première partie on te dis va te
tient dans tel type de principauté on va
faire ceci
non ici et c'est plutôt sur la nature
même du pouvoir exercé par le prince
donc ça c'est assez intéressant aussi et
on va faire un petit retour sur ce
concept de libéralités que je n'ai pas
bien compris dans le sens du texte voilà
je pense qu'il ya une évolution sur ce
terme alors j'ai la version
livre où on aura des écarts dans les
traductions ça ça va être aussi
intéressant à prendre en compte
mais donc le chapitre 16 il nous parle
de la libéralité et parcimonie
et 6 et 10
voilà de la libéralité de la valise
docteur de petits écarts aussi de
traduction qui parfois permettront
peut-être d'y voir un peu plus clair je
dis aussi que j'ai pas lu la notice
introductif qui parfois donne des
informations intéressantes mais parfois
pas parce que j'ai déjà vu des notices
instructif totalement dingue avec des
erreurs
voilà alors ça dépend sont des
collections mais je me méfie vraiment
des commentaires alors je lui disais
tout à l'heure que j'allais moi même
voir les commentaires après la lecture
mais c'est justement après la lecture et
donc je me méfie quand même deux
des commentaires comme ça a priori
donc ça c'est un chapitre qu'on abordera
pour en comprendre vraiment le sens et
peut-être que vous pouvez m'aider à ce
moment là et puis on terminera sur sur
quelques éléments alors je rappelle que
on va vraiment butiner dans chacun des
chapitres et de ce parti pris parce
qu'évidemment on peut pas lire toute
l'oeuvre comme ça ça serait vraiment
chez ans déjà comme ça je pense qu'on
est sûr sur de la niche de niche mais
avec cette méthode on risque parfois de
passer sur une chose plus essentiel qui
est transversal voire parfois même faire
des contresens de par le fait de faire
une sélection
bonsoir prof le nain comment vas tu ça
va bien
alors nicolas machiavel à qui
s'adresse-t-il à bien il s'adresse au
prince au prince
de l'époque laurent de médicis est donc
là on va directement avoir une
une introduction de machiavel même
et je vois que sur
vous
si on si on ne l'a pas
c'est pas grave je vais vous le dire
parce que c'est vraiment intéressant
la coutume la plus fréquente chez ceux
qui veulent gagner la faveur d'un prince
c'est de se présenter à lui avec ceux de
leurs biens dont ils font le plus de cas
où donc il le voit faire ces délices
aussi leur voix ton très souvent offert
des chevaux des armes des brocarts
un broker c'est le mal du chevreuil
pierres précieuses et autres ornements
digne de leur grandeur comme donc je
désirais m'offrira votre magnifier ce
magnifique sens donc là c'est laurent de
médicis avec quelques témoignages de ma
soumission envers elle je les trouvais
dans mon bagage chose dont je fasse plus
de cas et des steam que la connaissance
des actions des grands hommes
connaissance que m'ont enseigné une
longue expérience des choses modernes et
une lecture continuelle des anciennes et
ça c'est un aspect qu'on ne verra pas
dans la lecture d'aujourd'hui c'est
toutes les références historiques que
fait machiavel alors je ne le ferai pas
parce que comme on n'a pas franchement
j'ai pas forcément toutes les références
vous sans doute non plus c'est le truc
qui devient très vite chiant quand tu
comprends pas toutes les références
qu'on mais voilà is it est normalement
d'auteur antique il connaît très bien
l'histoire jusqu'à son époque
et donc il a vraiment une approche
analytique
comme je le disais il part vraiment de
choses concrètes et là on n'est pas sur
une approche philosophique de
philosophie politique il ya vraiment
quelque chose que j'aime bien dans le
sens observations empiriques
donc ça c'est cool
alors demain toujours partant pour le
pour le stream ah oui c'est vrai qu'on
avait dit demain quoi mais à quelle
heure demain
open 1 parce qu'avant et à le stream
politique
est ce que toi sa voix ça va si on fait
ça plus tard dans la soirée
moi ça m'arrangerait bien parce que
comme tu vois voilà 20h30 et à
l'émission politique
disons je sais pas vers 22h 22h30 ça
irait et puis on se met en route quand
on fait on fait quoi une une à deux
heures de stream
mise en route machin
faire ça ouais ça va super
donc demain c'est noté avec prof le nain
ont fait un stream squad sur tropicaux 6
on fera les
la mise en place la mise en place et on
prendra possession de notre île avec
notre ligne politique puisque on aura
chacun a un rôle à jouer
et c'est faudra aussi reparler
et encore que je juge cette oeuvre
indigne de lui et de présenter j'ai
cependant pleine confiance que grâce à
son humanité elle recevra en bonne part
considère en deux mois que deux mois ne
lui peut venir plus grand don que de lui
offrir le moyen de pouvoir en très peu
de temps comprendre tout ce que j'ai moi
mis tant d'années au prix de tant de
fatigue et de périls à connaître à
comprendre main comme il a été
fonctionnaire comme il a été un
observateur direct des évolutions
politiques de son temps et bien voilà il
en fait une synthèse donc c'est vraiment
une démarche tout à fait originale cette
heure je n'avais pas orné chargé de
formules ample de parole en poulet est
magnifique ou de ses autres parures
ornements extrinsèque dont beaucoup ont
coutume du street brodé leur récit car
j'ai voulu ou que rien ne lui fit
honneur ou que seule la différence de la
matière et la gravité du sujet la face à
gré et donc ça c'est sympa aussi parce
qu'on a un style qui est tout à fait
aussi moderne au l'époque dans le sens
où c'est assez direct et c'est vrai que
bon après voilà c'est quand même un
écrit qu'il ya 4 500 en mai en dépit de
ça c'est un truc qui se lit super bien
et donc merci machiavel de ne pas voir
de ne pas avoir en poule et le propos
alors ça c'est pour l'introduction et
puis vous voyez que les différents
chapitres combien ya deux sortes de
principautés alors là on parle de
principauté dans ma traduction on parle
plutôt de monarchie monarchie
principauté
c'est chou vert et vert chou donc là il
n'y a pas de lézard à se faire par
rapport à ça et donc ici va nous
vraiment nous faire une typologie comme
j'ai dit c'est l'heure des différentes
monarchie et par quels moyens on peut
les accueillir les acquérir
premier type de monarchie les monarchies
les principautés héréditaire 1 est donc
ici je dis donc que les pour les états
et militaires est façonnée à
l'obéissance envers la famille du prince
il ya bien moins de difficultés à les
maintenir que les états nouveau parce
qu'il ya une sorte pour machiavel
d'accoutumance les gens sont habitués à
obéir à la famille du prince sont
habitués qui une possession du pouvoir
par cette famille là et donc en fait ils
sont assez docile pour paraphraser
machiavel
parce qu'il suffit seulement de ne pas
altérer l'ordre établi par ses
prédécesseurs
et puis de temporiser avec les
événements de façon que si les d'une
habileté ordinaire intel prince toujours
se maintiendra dans son état s'il ne
survient une force extraordinaire
excessifs qu'ils en privent et s'il en
est privé au premier revers l'occupant
il le recouvre lorsque je trouve
incroyable dans la pensée de machiavel
dans ses écrits c'est que finalement tu
es vraiment sur une pratique du pouvoir
tel quel parfois les télés fait
maintenant quand tu vois le pouvoir d'
emmanuel macron qui est plus geste
gestionnaire qu'autre chose alors on
pourrait dire pour débattre sur le fait
ce qui est gestionnaire ce que les
réformateurs mais voilà il gère les
choses telles qu'elles arrivent et ben
en fait c'est très machiavélique dans le
sens du prince puisque
machiavel ne parle jamais d'eux il faut
faire ceci il faut faire cela en termes
de fonds ou en termes de politique à
mener c'est toujours avec une visée
pratique alors quand il dit il faut
faire ceci pour faire cela c'est
toujours pour maintenir le pouvoir et
pour qu'il y ait
alors il en parle pas comme ça mais j'ai
envie de dire une harmonie une harmonie
parce que il le dira plus loin pour lui
le mieux c'est quand tu n'utilises pas
la force et que tu as un consentement
des
gouvernés évidemment
j'ai une mouche qui me tourner autour
c'est particulièrement pénible je vais
ouvrir la fenêtre pour essayer de la
faire
dégagé
voilà
les principautés oulémas monarchie mixte
de quoi s'agit-il
donc il nous dit tout de suite que c'est
dans les principautés nouvelle que
toutes les difficultés se rencontrent et
donc si tu mets en place une monarchie
c'est là que tu risque d'aller dans le
ravin parce que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et surtout si les gens étaient
habitués à vivre sous la liberté
et il dit que c'est très compliqué aussi
à mettre en place parce que toujours en
effet quand bien même on aurait une très
forte armée on a besoin pour entrer dans
un pays de la faveur des habitants et ça
s'est jamais gagner évidemment
il est bien vrai que lorsque l'on
conc'air des pays qui se sont ainsi
révélés on les perd plus difficilement
le conquérant se prévalant de cette
rébellion procède avec moins de mesures
dans les moyens d'assurer sa conquête
soit en punissant les coupables sont en
recherchant les suspects soit en
fortifiant toutes les parties faibles de
ces états et donc ça c'est vraiment un
mode d'emploi qui te donne ici quand tu
crées une nouvelle principauté
alors comme je le stream dans mon
bouquin c'est les pauvres soit une bonne
idée ce jeu retrouve pas forcément tous
les passages
voilà ici deux conseils assez important
dans le premier cas il est facile de les
conserver surtout qu'ils ne sont point a
coutume est à vivre libres on est sur
les anciennes les monarchies qui
existait déjà pour les possédants sûreté
il suffit d'avoir éteint la race du
prince qui était le m et dans ce cas là
bas tu n'as qu'à remplacer
l'ancien prince par le nouveau prince
est à dire toi
mais dans le second cas c'est à dire
quand les états en a qui sont dans une
autre contrée que celui auquel on les
réunit quand ils n'ont ni la même langue
ni les mêmes heures ciné même
institution alors les difficultés sont
excessives et il faut un grand bonheur
et une grande habileté pour les
conserver un des moyens les meilleurs le
plus efficace serait que le vainqueur 20
et fixé sa demeure personnel donc
conseils que nous donne
machiavel va habiter là où tu veut
dominer
tu te fera quand même plus de d'amitié
que d'illimité
quand ils habitent le pays le nouveau
prince voient les désordres leur
naissance et pelé réprimer sur le champ
s'il en est éloigné il ne les connaît
que lorsqu'ils sont déjà grands et qu'il
ne lui est plus possible d'y remédier
d'ailleurs sa présence empêche ces
officiers de dévorer la province est en
tout cas c'est une satisfaction pour les
habitants d'avoir pour ainsi dire sous
la main le recours au prince même ils
ont plus de raisons soit de l'est mais
s'ils veulent être de bons et fidèles
sujets soit de la crainte s'ils veulent
s'ils veulent être mauvais enfin
l'étranger qui voudraient essayer cet
état c'est hazard bien moins aisément
d'autant que le prince y résident il est
très vite difficile de le lui enlever
alors ils conseillent aussi dans ce cas
là c'est de créer une colonie
comme le ont pu le faire les romains
certains points coin les romains dans
les pays dont ils s'emparèrent
observèrent bien ces divers points il y
envoya des colonies protégèrent les
moins puissants sans accroître leur
puissance a baissé à les puissants et ne
laissèrent pas les puissants être angers
il prend de l'importance
alors chapeau leucate pourquoi alors
envoyé par exemple ya des références
historiques qui nous dépasse un petit
peu comme étape darius des choses comme
ça
à considérer les difficultés qu'on a
conservé un état nouvellement conquis
d'aucun pourrait s'étonner se demandant
d'où vint qu'alexandre le grand de 20
mètres de l'asie en quelques années
ayant à peine achevé de sont emparés
mourut doute il paraissait logique que
ce pays se révolta néanmoins lé
successeur d'alexandre si maintien ça
c'est intéressant que aussi comme
analyse parce qu'on te dit en fait le
prince hylas différents différentes
configurations qui s'offre à lui alors
parfois il les choisit pas soit le pays
est administré par
des serviteurs qui sont des ministres et
donc qu'ils sont vraiment soumis
directement ou prince ou alors par des
barons qui ont eux mêmes un pouvoir sur
le territoire et qui ont une sorte d'al
les gens sont dans un système féodal une
sorte d' allégeance au prince
est dit que
dans un cas c'est plus difficile de
l'acquérir mais plus facile de le garder
et inversement
le contraire arrivent les avec les
royaume gouverné comme la france car
c'est avec facilité qu'on y peut entrer
en gagnant quelques barons du royaume
parce que la france est un pays de baron
car toujours on trouve des mécontents et
des gens qui souhaite des changements
donc dans un pays où il ya des bas on va
te ra toujours un baron qui se trouvent
lésés par rapport aux autres ou par
rapport au pouvoir central et donc qui
va être ton alliés ça sera valable aussi
quand toi tu seras au pouvoir tandis que
quand tu as
toute une caste qui est à la solde du du
prince c'est plus difficile à prendre
possession de ce royaume là mais c'est
plus facile une fois cuillé parce que tu
mettras toi même ton administration et
le tour sera joué
chapitre 5
comment il faut gouverner les cités ou
monarchie qui avant qu'elles fussent
cons qu'ils vivaient sous leur loi
alors ça c'est aussi intéressant lorsque
le pays qu'on acquiert comme on a dit
son accoutumée à vivre sont leurs lois
et en liberté pour tenir il ya trois
procédés le premier les détruire en
moins c'est dit le deuxième il ya les
habitants personnes j'apparais dans
d'autres configurations le troisième les
laisser vivre son leur loi en en tirant
un tribut et en y créant un gouvernement
oligarchie qui te conservent leur amitié
car créée par ce prince ce gouvernement
c'est qu'il ne peut durer sans son
amitié et sa puissance et doit tout
faire pour le maintenir
au chapitre 6 qu'est ce que j'ai retenu
l'on peut le passé on va pas tout faire
oui impasse peu retirée de son contexte
et quand même assez
révélateur de la pensée de machiavel
même si c'est peut-être un peu réducteur
et bien dans le chapitre
oui ça
sur cela il est à observer que celui qui
usurpe un état doit déterminer et
exécuter tout d'un coup toutes les
cruautés qu'il doit commettre pour
qu'ils n'aient pas y revenir tous les
jours et qu'il puisse en évitant de les
renouveler rassurer les esprits et les
gagner par des bienfaits celui qui par
timidité ou par mauvais conseils se
conduit autrement se trouve dans
l'obligation d'avoir toujours le glaive
en main il ne peut jamais compter sur
ces sujets tenue sans cesse dans
l'inquiétude par des injures continuer
les récentes les cruautés doivent être
commises tout à la fois pour que leur
amertume se faisant moins sentir l élite
- les bienfaits au contraire doivent se
succéder lentement pour qu'il soit
savourer davantage sur toute chose le
preuve le prince doit se conduire envers
ces sujets de telle manière qu'on ne le
voit point variées sur la circonstance
bonnes ou mauvaises s'il attend d'être
contraint par insistait à faire le mal
le bien il arrivera ou qu'il ne sera
plus à temps de faire le mal ou que bleu
bien qu'il fera ne lui profitera prendre
un point car on le croira fait par force
et on ne lui on saura aucun regret
d'ailleurs c'est exactement ce qui
arrive à mâcon qui parfois on a
l'impression qui va concéder certaines
choses parce que il ya justement une
pression qui est cayla et donc du coup
il n'en retire aucun profit
ouais c et qui sait recadrer là tu as
bien compris le l'intérêt du texte c'est
vraiment on est sur un truc est pas du
tout philosophique qui est vraiment
ultra pragmatique qui est très terre à
terre et là on va arriver au chapitre 15
et on va comprendre un petit peu la
vision de mch event
alors c'est intéressant parce qu'ici
nous dit de la principauté civile au
chapitre 9 alors une principauté où une
monarchie civile qu'est ce que ça
pourrait être je dis qu'on accède à
cette monarchie ou par la faveur du
peuple ou par celle des grands celui qui
parvient la monarchie à la laine avec
l'aide des grands se maintient avec plus
de difficulté que celui qui le devient
avec l'aide du peuple car il se trouve
prince au milieu de force de gens de
force
et donc après il continue et nous dit et
puis avec un peuple au style un prince
ne peut jamais être en sûreté parce
qu'ils sont trop contre les grands il
peut s'assurer pour être pu ainsi
quiconque devient prince par la faveur
du peuple doit se le maintenir en amitié
et celui qu'il y sera facile
ce qui lui sera par ici par dont le
peuple nous menons cas n'être pas
opprimées et donc là c'est un chapitre
qui est intéressant parce qu'il montre
que machiavel s'est pas non plus
quelqu'un qui contre le peuple forcément
parce qu'il dit la meilleure façon de
faire c'est cette monarchie civile dans
lequel le peuple est respectée et une
sorte de populisme populisme médiévale
supplie dire ça comme ça mais c'est
vraiment ça
est juste ne pas au prix opprimés les
jambes déjà avec ça tu peux te maintenir
assez facilement
exactement
bon j'ai rien auto shop dix chapitres
prononce les mots n'allait principauté
où les monarchies ecclésiastiques
bon là il nous dit que c'est des
monarchies qui sont sûres et heureuse
parce qu en fait voilà il ya quelque
chose il ya dieu coco dessus la croyance
en dieu qui est là au dessus qui vient
finalement maintenir la société la
cohésion de la société
donc pour lesquels toutes les
difficultés sont avant qu'on les possède
alors voilà c'est très difficile de
prendre possession d'une monarchie
ecclésiastique caire elle s'acquiert ou
par talent ou par chance et sans l'un et
l'autre se conserve cas elles sont
soutenues par des institutions
traditionnelles de la région l'a tout
simplement
alors on verra on verra tout à la fin
pourquoi est-ce que machiavel en tant de
peine à exploser tout ça il ya vraiment
une finalité politique il ya peut-être
une finalité finalité philosophie quand
même un fond de pensée mais il ya
d'abord une finalité très pratique pour
son époque
alors après on arrive sur trois
chapitres qui pour moi sont peut-être
moins intéressant c'est sur les
différents types d'armes et où il nous
dit que des troupes de mercenaires c'est
vraiment pas l'idéal et les milices non
plus
dans les troupes auxiliaires pardon
c'est pas c'est pas terrible non plus
lassé des considérations qui ne sont pas
très intéressante et puis un niveau pas
mieux chapitre u15
où il ya quand même quelque chose qui
est remarquable
il reste à examiner comment un prince
doit user et se conduire au musée se
conduire soit envers ces sujets soit
envers ses amis tant d'écrivains en ont
parlé que peut-être on me taxera de
présomptions
si j'en parle encore d'autant plus qu'en
traitant cette manière je vais m'écarter
de la route commune et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant mais dans le dessin
que j'ai d'écrire des choses utiles pour
celui qui me lira et on verra à la fin
quelles sont ses finalités il m'a appelé
il m'a paru qu'il valait mieux m'arrêter
à la réalité des choses que de me livrer
à de vaines spéculations ce qui est dit
autrement ici mais mon intention est
temps d'écrire des choses utiles à celui
qui l'entend il m'a apparu plus
pertinent de me conformer à la vérité
effective de la chose cosy mini aux
imaginations qu'on s'en fait et donc
c'est ça qui est beau je trouve chez
machiavel c'est vraiment cette volonté
d'aller au contact du réel alors qu'à
l'époque ben voilà on fait des
élucubrations on est aussi moraliste le
très fort dans les tic mais ma cave elle
lui vraiment fait une observation très
pratique en fait quasi j'ai envie de
dire
dépolluer de toute représentation de
tout sentiment personnel et on voit on
voit dans ce que tu disais phoenix c'est
très pratique c'est c'est vraiment très
sec en fait même où il ya aucune opinion
il ya aucune évidemment qu'à des
opinions mais en tout cas on voit que sa
volonté c'est vraiment de décrire les
choses telles qu'elles sont et pas tel
qu'il envie qu'elle soit et ça qui est
intéressant je trouve chez machiavel et
là c'est ce que certains auteurs
appellent la partie méthodologique du
prince 1 c'est vraiment cette phrase qui
est ici qu
alors chapitre suivant qui est un petit
peu
obscur pour moi
commençons donc par les premières
qualités susdite jeudi qu'il serait bon
d'être tenu pour libéral toutefois
exercé de cette façon de telle façon que
tu sois tenue pour telle la libéralité
de nuit
et après on y développe en fait le terme
libéral est complètement différent de ce
qu'on dise qu'on pourrait on penser
aujourd'hui qu'en
ski dit au nom du libéralisme est
nécessaire de ne négliger aucune sorte
de magnificence si bien que toujours un
prince ainsi p consumera ans semblable
oeuvre toutes ses ressources et sera
contraint la fin s'il veut conserver le
nom libéral de grever ses peuples de
façon extraordinaire de recourir aux
extorsions fixie fiscale et de faire
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour avoir de
l'argent
tiens ça me rappelle aussi quelqu'un
nous voilà donc pour ce faire pour
essayer de d'investiguer là dessus j'ai
pris je pense que c'est un bouquin une
fois que tu t'intéresses au classique tu
obligé d'avoir ça c'est un le
dictionnaire historique de la langue
française
ça permet d'avoir l'évolution d'un terme
dans le temps
et donc on va aller voir ce que dit
libéral j'ai pas encore fait l'exercice
parce que je voulais le faire avec vous
lillebonne
libéral
emprunter du latin en
ou latin libéralise délivrer des dérivés
de l'ibère libre évidemment qui comme un
genius
libérera l'état rue avec ce sens
psychologique encore en usage mais
supplanté par généreux son sens
étymologique digne d'un homme libre
est sorti d'usagé mais reste réalisé
dans le
voilà comme termes politiques libérales
est à tester pour la première fois en
1750 donc
qu'on machiavel utilise ici le terme
libéral c'est pas dans le sens de
libérales telles que nous on l'entend on
est dans le sens
psychologique
qui concerne un homme libre au sens
figuré psychologique de digne d'un homme
libre c'est-à-dire bienfaisant et
généreux mais je vois pas du coup dans
le texte pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un
qui serait généreux
après en étant trop généreux va arriver
extorquer sa population donc pour moi
c'est un chapitre qui reste un peu
obscur
oui mais c'est pour ça que moi j'aime
bien les classiques quand tu dis les
vieux penseurs ont raison c'est des
houthis et des outils qui sont qui sont
là à la disposition et je pense que
voilà tu peux tu peux pas avoir une
pensée
profonde
si tu cites a pas en connaissance toute
l'évolution de la pensée politique ou
philosophique ou social ça dépend ce que
tu veux ce que tu veux investiguer co
mais c'est clair qu'il ya toujours des
éléments d'actualité alors ici
évidemment il ya l'effet de lecture
l'effet loupe puisque je retire des
éléments qui me semblent les plus
pertinents après à plein de choses qui
sont
moins actuelle mais il ya toujours des
éléments à retirer des auteurs
classiques c'est pour ça que
que j'aime bien ce à quoi
je vous proposer que j'espère sa
rencontre une demande quand même
alors chapitre 17 est ce qu'il vaut
mieux être aimé que craint
alors est-ce qu'il faut mieux être aimé
que craint l inverse on répond qu'on
voudrait être l'un et l'autre mais comme
il est difficile de les marier ensemble
il est beaucoup plus sûr d'être crinqué
mais quand on doit manquer de l'un d'eux
donc voilà encore une fois pour pas
résumer machiavel au terme machiavélique
en disant à machiavel c'est vraiment
prendre le pouvoir avec sans foi ni loi
maintenant il le dit si il le dit il
vaut mieux les deux mais c'est pas
possible toujours d'être craints et mais
à la fois donc si c'est pas possible les
2 équi et qu'on peut choisir il vaut
mieux prendre la crainte que la mort
le prince doit se faire craindre en
sorte que si elle n'acquiert pas l'amour
il évite la haine car être craints et
n'être pas ils peuvent très bien se
trouver ensemble et cela arrivera
toujours pourvu qu'ils s'abstiennent des
biens de ses concitoyens et de ses
sujets et de leurs femmes donc ça pour
ma cavale c'est super important que tu
n'as jamais prendre les biens des autres
et les femmes alors c'est une pensée qui
est misogyne
à cette époque là on verra que tout à
l'heure il ya un passage qui est pas
tiré des verts sur la misogynie
et quand pourtant il lui faudra procéder
contre le sens de quelqu'un le faire
pourvu qu'il y ait une justification
convenable et une cause manifeste donc
éviter toute violence arbitraire donc on
voit quand même que comme machiavel
c'est quand même
c'est voilà c'est pas du sans foi ni loi
je pensais ce qu'il faut retenir ici la
lecture car les hommes oublient plus
vite la mort de leur père que la perte
de leur patrimoine clip dit bien sûr
tout ne pas toucher au patrimoine des
des gens
combien il serait louable chez un prince
de tenir sa parole et de vivre avec
droiture et non avec russ chacun
comprend toutefois on voit par
expérience et on en revient toujours à
cette observation directe de la réalité
politique il a pu observer ou de ce
qu'il a pu lire de nos jours que tel
prince ont fait de grandes choses qui de
leurs paroles ont tenu peu de comptes et
qui ont su par ruse manoeuvrer la
cervelle des gens et à la fin ils ont
dominé ceux qui se sont fondés sur la
loyauté donc encore une fois machiavel
te dis pas non non il faut ruser au lieu
d'être honnête il te dis pas ça il te
dit c'est mieux d'être honnête mais le
problème c'est que tu te fais avoir on
n'est pas dans le monde des bisounours
un vraiment machiavel si je pouvais le
résumé avec une phrase moderne c'est on
n'est pas dans le monde des bisounours
puis donc qu'un prince est obligé de
savoir bien user de la bête il doit
parmi elle rendra oui pardon je devais
tout lire sinon vous n'allez pas
comprendre ça et là c'est vraiment un
passage qui est important parce que il
est tellement important que sur la
couverture de la version ici chez
garnier flammarion oui un lion est un
renard bien ça c'est le passage ici que
je suis occupé de vous lire
vous devez donc à voir qu'il ya deux
manières de combattre l'une avec les
lois l'autre avec la force la première
est propre à l'homme la seconde est
celle des bêtes donc encore une fois ici
machiavel le dit bien mais non la
manière de gouverner humainement ce avec
des lois et pas avec la force mais comme
la première très souvent ne suffit pas
il convient de recourir à la seconde est
donc l'homme doit aussi se faire dette
à certains moments puis donc un prince
est obligé de savoir bien user de la
bête il doit parmi elles prendre le
renard et le lion car le lion ne se
défend pas d'airé ça c'est les filets
pour capturer le renard ne se fait
défend pas des loups ils font don heck
il fonde donc être un renard pour
connaître les ré et le lion pour au
frais les loups ceux qui s'en tiennent
simplement lyon n'y entendent rien un
souverain prudent par conséquent ne peut
ni ne doit observer sa foi quand une
telle observance tournerait contre lui
et que sont éteintes les raisons qui le
firent promettre et si les hommes
étaient tous bons ce précepte ne serait
pas bon mais comme ils sont méchants et
ne l'observeront est pas à toi toi non
plus tu n'as pas à l'observer avec eux
donc c'est un peu il pourra it en
perdant jamais un prince n'a manqué de
motif légitime pour colorer son manque
de foi de ceux là de cela l'on pourrait
donner une infinité d'exemple moderne et
montrer combien de paix combien de
promesses ont été rendus caducs even par
l'infidélité des princes donc ce n'est
pas nouveau les politiques qui ne
tiennent pas leurs paroles c'est pas
nouveau ça à minimum 500 ans mais il
faut cette nature savoir bien la colorée
et être un grand simulateur et
dissimulateur et j'ai toujours dit sur
le stream politique que la politique
c'était d'abord une question d'image
c'est un peu triste de résumer la
politique à ça mais c'est ça la
politique
encore une fois soyons machiavélique
dans le sens nous regardons les choses
telles qu'elles sont
et les hommes sont si simples ils
obéissent si bien en nécessité présente
que celui qui trompe trouvera trouvera
toujours qui se laissera tromper
c'est aussi un beau passage
aussi d'engins pitt qui répond aussi que
le peuple c'est la clé tout et que si tu
as le peuple avec toi c'est déjà une
bonne chose mais là c'est un chapitre
assez long donc je vais passer assez
vite
le chapitre je n'avais rien noté non
plus
de remarquables peut-être qu'on a dans
ma lecture c'est parce que j'avais
remarqué alors chapitre 21
ce qui convient au prince pour ce faire
estimé on estime aussi un prince quand
il est un vrai ami et un vrai ennemi
c'est intéressant c'est à dire quand
sans aucun ménagement il se découvre en
faveur de quelqu'un contre un autre
parti qui sera toujours plus utile que
de rester neutre en machiavel les contre
la neutralité car si tu as deux
puissants voisins qui en viennent aux
mains où ils sont de telles qualités que
l'un d'eux triomphante eu doivent
craindre le vainqueur ou non en l'un et
l'autre de ces deux cas il sera toujours
plus utile de te découvrir et de faire
bonne guerre car dans le premier cas si
tu ne te découvre pas tu seras toujours
en proie 2 qui vint avec plaisir
satisfaction de celui qui a été vaincue
et tu n'as ni bon droit ni bonnes ni
choses aucune qui te protège ni qui
t'offre refuge en effet qui vint ne veut
point d'amis suspect et qui ne l'aide
pas dans l'adversité qui perd ne te
reçois pas pour n'avoir pas toi voulu
les armes à la main partager sa fortune
et ici il faut noter qu'un prince doit
prendre garde de ne faire jamais
compagnie avec un plus puissant que lui
pour attaquer autrui sinon quand la
nécessité le contraint comme ci dessus
l'ont dit car en vain quand tu demeures
sont prisonniers
puis à la fin lui deux chapitres et un
petit passage où
il fait un petit peu les loges désert
aussi
les ministres des princes
il des secrétaires des princes mais dans
ma traduction cdh ministre de printemps
et la première conjectures que l'on fait
du cerveau d'un mètre et de voir les
sommes qu'il a autour de lui 1 on peut
toujours toujours juger la qualité d'un
dirigeant à haut niveau de ses
conseillers et à ses conseillers
et quand ils sont capables les fidèles
on peut toujours le réputée sage
puisqu'il a su les juges est capable et
les maintenir fidèles mais quand ils
sont autrement on peut toujours porter
mauvais jugement sur lui car la première
erreur qu'il fait c'est dans ce choix
qu'il l'a fait
donc on comprend mieux aussi le temps
que met macron a décidé de son premier
ministre
parce que c'est toujours un signal la
qualité de des gens qui t'entourent et
quelqu'un comme marine le pen qui on a
souvent reproché tient de qui seraient
ses ministres finalement elle est seule
mais c'est ça le problème
tu dois donc choisir des seconds
couteaux des gens qui sont pas forcément
capables des gens qui sont pas forcément
compétent mais c'est toi même tu as
compétence qui est mise en cause
mais comment un prince pourra connaître
son ministre voici un moyen qui ne
trompe jamais quand tu vois le ministre
pensait plus à soi qu'à toi et que dans
toutes les affiches ils recherchent là
dedans son profit un tel homme ainsi
fait jamais ne sera bon ministre jamais
une pourra te fie à lui car celui qui à
l'état de quelqu'un on ne doit jamais
penser à soi mais toujours au prince et
ne jamais d'entretenir de choses qui ne
le concerne pas et d'un autre côté le
prince pour qu'ils restent bons doit
penser aux ministres en l'honorant en
l'enrichissant en le faisant sont
obligés en lui donnant sa part des
honneurs et des charges afin qu'ils
voient qu'il ne peut se substituer sans
lui subsister sur l'ubs en est que
l'abondance des honneurs ne lui fasse
pas désirer plus d'honneur
l'abondance des richesses ne lui fasse
pas désiré plus de richesses l'abondance
des cherche lui fasse craindre les
changements
le chapitre 23 m'a beaucoup parlé en
tout cas sur toute une partie c'est
comment il faut offrir les flatteurs et
moi j'ai toujours trouvé que un des gros
problèmes du pouvoir c'était ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le phénomène de cour
des gens qui t'entourent qui finalement
vont toujours te dire ce que tu fais et
biens ne devront jamais prendre le
le parti de te dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont à lamanère la manière de
machiavel vont toujours enrober les
choses pour que ça ne te blesse pas mais
finalement c'était plus mauvais
conseiller quoi je trouve
et hier on regardait encore cette
émission sur
les présidents aller son jour des
présidents qui est passé sur 32 qui est
très intéressante et tu vois que parfois
je les traits marqués par le fait mais
on a encore vu des reportages
aujourd'hui qui parlait de ça que
parfois les présidents prennent des gens
qui sont pas du tout à qui sont pas du
tout en phase en fait c'est par exemple
le cas de sarkozy qui prend comme
ministre martin hirsch d'emmaüs france
alors qu'ils s'entendent pas et smart
energy qui dit on s'entendait pas du
tout on était vraiment opposé quasi est
là quand même plus comme ministre mais
ça montre quand même la valeur de sarko
sur ce point-là de savoir s'entourer de
gens qui sont qui sont pas forcément du
même avis que lui justement pour être de
bons conseillers
sont les flatteurs de qui les cours sont
pleines car les hommes se complaisent
tantôt choses qui leur sont propres et
s'y trompe pas ce point qu'avec
difficulté ils se défendent de cette
peste et à s'en vouloir défendre on
court le danger de s'exposer au mépris
car il n'est point d'autres moyens de se
garder de la flatterie que de donner à
entendre aux gens qu'ils ne te sens pas
à te dire le vrai mais quand chacun peut
te dire le vrai on cesse de te respecter
et c'est ça le problème ce qui pourrait
justement choisir plein de gens qui sont
très très franc et très honnête avec toi
mal en ce moment là c'est une autorité
qui vont pâtir alors comment faire
c'est pourquoi un prince sage doit tenir
une troisième voie en faisant choix dans
son état d' homme éclairé et à seul à
seul à seul il doit donner toute licence
de lui dire la vérité est sûre cela seul
sur quoi il les interroge et rien
d'autre mais il doit les interroger sur
toute chose et entendre leur opinion
plus décider par lui-même à sa guise et
dans ses conseils avec chacun d'entre
eux se comportait de façon que chacun
connaisse que d'autant plus librement et
parlera est d'autant plus illusion saura
gré hormis cela ne vouloir entendre
personnes exécutées la chose décidé et
être obstiné dans ses décisions qui fait
autrement où il s'écroule à cause des
flatteurs où il change souvent à cause
de la diversité des avis d'où résulte qu
on fait de lui peu des styles y est donc
ce que dit bien ma cave elle sait que
ruy les gens doivent donner leur avis
mais quand tu leur demandes voilà
et là on rentre dans le
final mans l'objet vraiment où
l'objectif véritable du prince de
machiavel pourquoi les princes d'italie
ont perdu leur état
donc il rien trop à relever ici
si ce n'est là le propos global est ici
tu vois le dernier chapitre ses
exhortations à prendre l'italie et à la
délivrer des barbares quoi
en fait le risque de ma cavale c'est la
mort une l'italie unifiée et il aimerait
pourquoi pas que ce soit
ça soit le prince laurent de médicis qui
qui fassent cela est donc s'y met tous
assurent sur papier c'est vraiment pour
essayer d'avoir une l'italie unifiée
parce que c'est vraiment son objectif
ont en tout cas que plusieurs royaumes
de l'italie soit unifiée c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui le touche et là il a
tout un programme politique qu'ils
essaient d'influencer lui-même par ce
bouquin
voilà et pour terminer je termine sur le
passage qui est ultra misogyne qui a
souvent été discuté
c'est tout un chapitre qui parle en fait
de la fortune pour machiavel la fortune
c'est le côté le destin quoi le le
hasard aussi par le destin du laser
s'opposait la fortune les choses
finalement qu'on ne choisit pas qui
s'impose à nous de l'extérieur
les faits qu'on pourrait dire
voilà le fait qu'ils arrivent comme ça
quoi c'est un plat fortune mais il dit
sur ce coup là il est assez macro nist
j'ai envie de dire
je pense surplus qu'il vaut mieux être
impétueux que circonspect donc
machiavel reconnaît qu'il ya des
éléments sur lesquels on n'a pas pris et
ça j'aime bien parce que c'est assez
moderne c'est souvent ce que j'ai dit
dans les stream en disant mais
finalement les politiques on leur
reproche de ne pas tenir leurs
programmes mais c'est des idéaux et
après tu as toujours la réalité des
choses toujours la réalité des
événements qui arrivent à ce que
machiavel appelle la fortune et comment
tu dois faire par rapport à ça est ce qu
un saint amand tu dois accepter d'être
fataliste finalement circonspect ou
alors tu dois être impétueux tu dois
essayer de lutter contre l'inéluctable
et machiavel répond avec
passage je les dis assez assez violent
car la fosse fortune et femmes pour la
tenir soumises il faut la traiter avec
rudesse elle cède plutôt aux hommes qui
usent de la violence qu à ceux qui
agissent froidement aussi est-elle
toujours amis des jeunes gens qui sont
moins réservé plus emporté et qui
condamne avec plus d'audace
à côté du volontarisme de mâcon que moi
je je retrouve dans ce passage là bien
sûr son la misogynie
et bien voilà on a fait le tour de
de ce bouquin hawaïenne dernière chose
qu'on pourrait voir regarder ici sur le
quatrième de couverture et un petit
texte qui est écrit et qui m'a
directement interpellé c'est le très
pénétrants machiavel cet homme très sage
dont il est évident qu'il fut pour la
liberté pour la défense de laquelle il a
donné les conseils les plus salutaire et
qui dit ça a bien c'est ce bon vieux
spinoza dans le traité politique partie
et donc gelé ici et on va le voir ce que
dit exactement spinoza et a pas quelque
chose de plus détaillée alors le traité
politique de spinoza c'est une oeuvre
qui n'est pas terminée
puis nous avons mort avant d'avoir pu le
finir et un peu dommage parce que les
chapitres sur la démocratie ce qui
manque
alors il le dit chapitre 5
paragraphe 7 de
quels moyens un prince omnipotent dirigé
par son appétit de domination doit user
pour établir et maintenir son pouvoir le
très pénétrants machiavel la montre est
abondamment mais quand à la fin qui la
visait elle n'apparaît pas très
clairement
s'il s'en est proposée une bonne ainsi
qu il est à espérer d'un homme sage se
se semble être de montrer de quelle
imprudence la masse ses preuves alors
qu'elle supprime attirant tandis qu'elle
ne peut supprimer les causes qui font un
qu'un prince devient un tyran mais qu'au
contraire plus le prince à des sujets de
crainte plus il ya de cause propre à
faire de lui un tyran ainsi qu'il arrive
quand la multitude fait du prince un
exemple et glorifient un attentat contre
souverain comme un haut fait peut-être
machiavel at il voulu montrer aussi
combien la population doit se garder de
s'en remettre de son salut à un seul
homme qui s'il n'est pas vain au point
de se croire capable de plaire à tous
devra constamment craindre quelques
embûches et par là se trouvent
contraints de veiller surtout à son
propre salut est au contraire de tendre
des pièges à la population plutôt que de
veiller sur elle et je suis d'autant
plus disposés à juger ainsi de ce très
habile auteurs qu'on s'accorde à le
tenir pour partie un partisan constant
de liberté et que sur la façon dont il
faut la conserver il a donné des avis
très salutaire
bien voilà et on termine là dessus sur
du bon spinoza
voilà c'était un stream assez court mais
bon voilà cdc des oeuvres qui sont quand
même relativement limités dans leur
portée pour nous on ne parle pas de
caisse que la propriété de proudhon qui
est beaucoup plus rock and roll pour
nouer
et peut-être qu'il fait plus et qu à
nous à nous envier à nos besoins nos
volontés à nos attentes que le prince de
machiavel mais je trouvais ça
intéressant de faire ça au moins une
fois sur ce stream et bien je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée je remercie
propre nom et phoenix pour le petit
passage sur le chat et je vous dis à
très bientôt c'est à dire demain salut
salut